Do you have a charger? My name is Dermot O'connor
and I'm the Irish Freedom Party candidate
for the EU elections in Dublin
this June. The reason why I want to run in this election
is because I believe Ireland needs a real voice of opposition
and representation at an EU level.
And Dublin can provide that by turning its back on career politicians.
The EU migration pact is just one problem
that's coming from a European level
that will make it impossible for Ireland to catch up,
let alone keep up in housing demand.
This is making the price of housing
completely unaffordable for people in Dublin,
with the average house price now being at half a million euro.
An article recently detailed that a couple
made up of a garda and a north
can no longer afford a home in Dublin.
As your Dublin MEP,
I would fight to protect free speech and Irish neutrality
and we will fight to regain Ireland's autonomy.
As you're doubling MEP,
I will defend free speech from the European Union's attacks against it.
We will also fight against carbon taxes,
which are raising the cost of living from.
From end consumers to motorists and small businesses.
So that's why on June 7th,
I'll be asking for your number one in the European elections in Dublin.
Vote for the Irish Freedom Party
and let's regain autonomy of Ireland
from the European Union's control.